like a new stereotype that I would hear
would be like oh man Asians are really
good dancers thanks to you guys dude
that's probably the sickest thing that
could happen in my lifetime best thing
that ever happened to Asia I never grew
up with that because you guys set that
new stereotype for good dancers or their
power lifters because of this guy you
know this show blackish they licensed
the clip of us when the main characters
mad that Asians took dance from black
people
but it's like a positive thing and Asian
guys are just unholdable on the Dance
Floor come on dancing though
go-to's that's pretty crazy in 20 years
we're gonna see Asian kids going and I
don't know how to dance
exactly with tears thought all of us are
good dancers